- Hi, I'm Dylan Thuras of Atlas Obscura.
Welcome back to the YouTube Channel.
In case you've forgotten who I am,
what Atlas Obscura is,
what we're all doing here,
let me give you a quick refresher.
I'm Dylan,
Atlas Obscura is an organization dedicated
to the world's hidden wonders.
We've been growing our database
of 15 thousand places all over the world.
We also share incredible foods,
unusual dishes, and ingredients.
We are running events
all over the country.
We are taking trips all over the world
and on top of all of that,
we are gonna be adding a ton of new video,
incredible series to this YouTube channel.
We are gonna be doing more
than just 100 Wonders,
which was the main video previously.
We are gonna be giving you
a series about collectors.
People who have unbelievable
objects in their
homes, basements, barns.
We're gonna be doing series
about incredible artists
like a miniature artist
who builds little versions
of buildings about to be torn down.
Unbelievable skill and craftsmanship.
We're gonna do food videos
about how to make the
world's bounciest meatball.
It is so incredibly bouncy.
You would not believe how bouncy it is.
So, for all of you who love
the 100 Wonders series,
you're gonna see me, you're
gonna get videos about places
but, you're gonna meet new people.
Other members of the Atlas Obscura team
and all of its live here
on this YouTube channel.
We've already put some of
these videos up on the channel.
So, I would love it if you'd
wanted to go check those out.
Leave us a comment, let
us know what you think
and we're gonna be publishing
a new video every Tuesday.
So, set the little bell
thing that lets you know
there's a new video coming.
You can subscribe here
and if you are confused about
what I am talking about,
you should go to the website, atlasobscura.com.
You can see our trips, events,
stories, places database, everything
on the site.